[Music]
you
hello and welcome to our webcast MBA
student insights a Q&A with the Hispanic
business Student Association my name is
Ana Leyva and I'm a first year MBA
student here at the GSB and co-president
of Hispanic business Student Association
I'm joined by Danny Reyes
Madison Oba though my clan is sagasta me
and David Vasquez who are also MBA
students here and members of the
Hispanic business Student Association
we'll be talking about our journey to
the GSB the student experience here on
campus and HBS a of course and answering
as many of your questions as we can to
submit a question to s simply click on
the Q&A button at the bottom of your
screen please note that we won't be
answering questions about admissions the
application process or financial aid so
if you have questions about those topics
submit them directly to admissions by
emailing MBA admissions at GSB
stanford.edu we'll be starting with some
introductions Danny Matteson my son and
David please start by sharing a little
bit about you where you're from what you
were doing before the GSB
and what your plans are for after
graduation Danny let's start with you
sure so hi everyone I'm Danny Reyes I am
from Miami Florida come from Cuban human
immigrant parents before before the GSB
I I was I started business undergrad at
Penn and then I worked in consulting at
BCG out of their Chicago office spent
two years there and then worked for a
year at the PGA Tour where I spent
another year and after that came to the
GSB and then after GSB I'm looking to
stay with BCG in consulting and work on
some long term plans to to work in the
sports industry thanks Jeanne Madison
I'm from Dallas Texas my dad is a second
generation American from his family's
originally from Mexico northern Mexico
specifically I studied ethnic studies at
Brown with the focus on migration
studies after biz sorry after Brown I
went on a Fulbright to Mexico where I
worked with nonprofit organizations and
taught English the law school after
I did a hard pivot to the private sector
with crisis PR at a small firm in New
York after the GSB I'm hoping to go into
consulting for a couple of years and
longer term start my own nonprofit
focused on immigrant communities in the
u.s. thanks Madison Benny so I grew up
in Mexico City until I was 18 I did my
undergrad in the UK
I studied politics philosophy and
economics at Warwick and then
subsequently I joined the financial
services industry working for a bank in
Asia and the Middle East and then the
GSB of course now I'm not exactly sure
what I wanted to do afterwards
so I'm experimenting with like different
industries in locations to kind of
define exactly what's the next step
David hi everyone my name is David
Vasquez I'm from Brooklyn New York where
I went to Columbia for undergraduate
economics after Columbia I went to
Investment Banking then I did some stint
in private equity than I actually
pivoted to nonprofit and did that for
two years at the GSB I'm also a joint
degree student with the master's in
public policy and long term I'm hoping
to do social impact investing and
hopefully pivot my career between public
and private sectors awesome as for me
I'm from the San Francisco Bay Area my
mom is from Mexico my dad's from
Nicaragua and before coming to GSB I was
I studied international relations at
Princeton undergrad and then worked in
Enterprise tech sales and after the GSB
I will probably be running my family
business okay so now that we have
introductions out of the way let's start
with your questions question one what
made you decide to apply to and attend
Stanford over other schools so for me
the first the first thing that cannery
caught my attention was the how dynamic
the environment was here being close to
a you know the tech space but the more I
started to know the community here what
really made my decision to come here was
just being aware of how like supportive
the community was about how
that people had done like really
interesting things but like also not so
conventional or at least not in my
industry and just how welcoming it was
to different perspectives yeah that
resonates with me I was attracted to
Stanford primarily because of the Center
for Social Innovation I'm hoping to
graduate with a certificate in public
management and social innovation and
there are so many resources and courses
here that attracted me to the school
initially and then similar to what my
Tony is saying after conversations with
friends who've gone to other business
schools the culture of Stanford really
attracted me and kind of reminded me of
the culture of brown which I enjoyed
yeah that can second that as a joint
degree student I was really looking for
a community that would be
multidisciplinary and I think Stanford
more than most other business schools is
exactly that I also wanted to I don't
think I'm a very entrepreneurial person
or big risk-taker but I definitely
wanted to be exposed to those type of
individuals and those type of ideas and
you know I've been here for what about
six months now I already feel as if you
know I'm thinking a little bit more
outside the box I'm collaborating across
different disciplines and again like
like Madonna said it says the community
is amazing and extremely supportive
throughout the entire journey yeah I
think my points are kind of in covered
but as someone who didn't come from tech
didn't come from the startup world grew
up in the East Coast worked in the
Midwest I was really looking for
something to push me out of my comfort
zone and that's something that I think
has been fulfilled here and happens over
and over again depending on which class
I'm in there which which group I'm with
at the moment and I can definitely echo
I've I feel like I'm so much more up to
speed on you know tech and-and-and
entrepreneurship and all that kind of
stuff
awesome thank you how certain were you
on the career you wanted to pursue prior
to starting your MBA I had no idea
consulting kind of fell into my lap
naturally the thing I enjoyed most about
my last job it was similar it was Client
Services they're advising people on
communication strategies and really
mission critical moments
I realized I liked the dynamic
environment and exposure to different
different industries so consulting
seemed a natural fit in terms of getting
exposure to more quantitative analytical
problems while still maintaining those
client relationships and exposure to
different industries though I no longer
term nonprofit social sectors where I'd
like to end up for me I came in knowing
I wanted to work in sports long term and
that was great because ahead of time I
was looking at you know which professors
do I want to make connections with you
know which which alumni do I want to
potentially create connections with but
as I've been here I've been I've been
tempted so many times to to change my
path drastically because it you just get
exposed to so many different industries
in so many different areas that you know
Stanford can kind of help you work
towards that I even though I was set
going in I had I've had so many times so
many times where I've been challenged on
that and have thought about so many
different industries and areas so like I
said I I'm still figuring that part out
but what I what I've really enjoyed
about the process is that I think I
think a lot of the resources and a lot
of the mindset at Stanford is to really
work with your type of time right so
people who know exactly what they want
to go into and they're they're super
super focused
they'll get the right resources to to
get there you know as efficiently and as
far as possible whereas you know for
other people who are exploring different
like locations or different industries
there's also that you know that other
approach to to career management and
career finding and so you know right now
I'm just looking at the different
opportunities there is to explore
locations and industries and really
making the most out of it because you do
have a lot of exposure to learn about
different things here definitely I
definitely second what Danny was saying
I came in with a pretty clear mindset of
what I wanted to do I had done finance I
had no idea whether I want to do that
again I drastically left and went to you
know the public sector worked in
non-profit and I found myself wanting to
marry the to in some way so social
impact investing kind of just made sense
but you know as I've been here and I've
as
different paths and what I think
Stanford does a really good job of is
showing you many different paths making
them very tangible so you kind of know
exactly what to do if you want to get to
different directions and you get to talk
to a lot of different people especially
your classmates about what they did
before so you see yourself taking kind
of the passions that you think you had
coming in but finding other places to
set them so you know now I'm still
considering different options in fact
magic sauce is something I want to try
out but I'm definitely not more open
than I was coming on and to that point
talking to classmates has been probably
the one of the best resources you know
in terms of figuring out careers and
figuring out you know what industries
might suit you best
and everyone I don't know if you guys
feel the same but I feel like everyone
here has been so open and so welcoming
about like sharing their experience and
like grabbing coffee with you for for
thirty minutes to talk about their what
they've done in the past and all that
kind of stuff which is been really
helpful you get a lot of people who are
super sure about what they wanted to do
but just going through that process that
you talked about of like being exposed
to a whole range of different things
just get them to be like super sure
about it or like it really does like
spark something new and there's people
who like make pivots and just change
completely where they thought they would
go into coming in here that's very cool
until like after that really briefly you
know I think the coolest part too is
that everyone's going through the same
journey here so maybe yeah in your old
jobs you feel like you were outlier cuz
maybe you weren't sure if you fit and
you wanted to pivot maybe you're the
only one that goes to business school
but here everyone's going through the
same journey so it's really cool to kind
of go to that journey with other people
so even if you feel like there's never
enough time to go through everything you
can see other journeys and see if they
actually fit with you and it's just a
great experience one quick thing a plug
for sort of the institutional resources
at Stanford beyond the Career Management
Center you also have access to schools
across the street which are the other
grad schools at Stanford so like the
design school for instance can really
help shape your thinking around like
visualizing the life that you want and I
think that's really unique to Stanford
as a business school student absolutely
I can echo that I've felt so inspired
here and yeah at times even a bit
distracted like oh maybe you should do
that or that sounds interesting because
there's just so much going on and we
know that the MBA is a general degree
right and a degree where leadership the
leadership skills that we're learning
here are really going to be applicable
to many different career paths one of
our questions is what have you learned
about leadership that you didn't already
know so what have you learned here at
Stanford that you didn't already know
about leadership specifically I'll start
again
so to give a little background on kind
of a class we all take first quarter
called leadership labs so you work in a
small team of five or six students you
know that typically come from a wide
variety of backgrounds and you work
through different role plays and through
different exercises you give each other
all kinds of feedback you have an MBA
too
who's been trained on leadership and in
these topics that's kind of overseeing
the group and its really a crash course
on leadership is the way I look at it
throughout the whole first quarter and
to answer your question I think the the
one thing I learned was how to
strategically bring out how to
strategically facilitate bringing out
the best of everyone on your team and
making sure that you know one person
isn't taking up too much space or one
person you know who may not may not be
as inclined to interrupt someone or you
know speak their mind extremely openly
how to bring out how to bring out and
kind of balance the conversation to make
sure you're getting diverse perspectives
and the best out of everyone in terms of
leadership labs those are really
inspiring and also transformative course
for me today
but I took away from it is that anyone
can be a leader you can come in and be
more introverted more extroverted but it
really provides people with a platform
to experiment with different styles
which I thought was an awesome
opportunity and one other thing is we're
filmed a few times in that classroom
it's very fun and grah humbling to see
yourself on the screen with classmates
so yeah
I've learned not to continue the
lovefest on lead labs but I completely
let go everything here so you know for
some context lead labs you provide
feedback with each other and I found
very similar to what Madison said that
anyone could be a leader and I found
myself actually you know pivoting my own
leadership style based on the things
that I saw and others that I really
admired so for example there was someone
who was quiet confident more laid-back
I'm more of a leaning kind of louder
person and I - I found myself really
wanting to spend time with this other
person to learn how do they manage the
stressful environments when they're
leading back and the cool part was he
was like hey I actually really wanted to
learn how you lean in and you know just
learning how to adapt yourself to two
different situations and really start to
read the rooms and understand okay this
is you know leadership is all about
adaptation so you know when when to be
that quiet leader when to be that that
louder leader wants to be a listener
when to be a questionaire so all that
kind of adaptation that kind of comes
through Lee Labs was a great place to
kind of you know to experiment yeah I'm
not going to talk about labs so I think
I think would you learn a lot here I
mean you learned a lot about yourself I
think that's true of a lot of programs
but I think what's unique here it's dad
the when we speak about the culture I
think it has a lot of emphasis on not
only your self-awareness but also in
having other people participate in that
transformation right so so when we talk
about how do you provide a feedback how
to help people along their journey and
how to like also bring in your your own
journey to other people I think that's
what's really important I think Stanford
really tries to make you kind of cross
certain like boundaries that you may
have set for yourself like fake
boundaries that you're like oh I would
never tell this to someone or I would
never have this conversation because
it's very difficult and then all of a
sudden you find yourself in situations
where you are going to cross that line
but it is in a really positive way right
in a positive way that makes you grow
and really makes you work better and and
just be more aware of how you interact
with others so I think for me that's
been the biggest like parting like
Leadership Development
yeah that's awesome thanks for sharing
and another question we've received is
about a best or most memorable course
and you already mentioned lead labs at
depth at length so maybe beyond lead
labs at best or most memorable class
that you've taken so far I've really
liked information of new ventures here
so the format of the class is that you
have so the objective is that you're
going to learn about the different the
different ways that startups underwent
this this whole like a journey from idea
to to financing to setting up their
teams to everything that set them up
either first success or not success and
so what the professor's do is they bring
in the entrepreneurs right so the people
who actually went through this will come
to class and then you'll they'll talk
about you know how they set up their
teams what was important what did they
learn what were like tough moments and
then you get to interview so I like an
entrepreneur of your choosing so it's a
really it's a different format of class
and I really enjoy the fact that the
people who actually you know we're in
the case studies would come to class and
talk to you about their experience sort
of mirroring that I took formation of
impact ventures which is the same model
but focused on social impact
organizations which was amazing so I
won't repeat too much because it sounds
like the same format which was
incredible but I really enjoyed product
launch which is the advanced marketing
class it was a nice opportunity to apply
what we have learned in the Fall Quarter
to just in terms of strategy financials
etc to figure out a how a product goes
from again idea to an actual company so
I enjoyed that yeah so I would say for
me and my favorite class was so far
fiscal policy so as someone who's doing
public policy master's I have no policy
experience so I was actually with my
first like four year into policy and
it's taught by Keith NSE who was you
know pretty high up in the Bush
administration has tons of real life
experience and the way he ran the class
was almost like a mock Senate or a mock
Congress where you know it was a lot of
cold calling kind of nervous at first
but you know you find yourself speaking
you know as if you're a congressman
or your you're pitching an idea or a
policy and you leave class late like wow
like I learned a ton and you know I just
think the the way that the class was set
up and the fact that it was not
necessarily something that was business
specific but kind of out of the realm
just made me appreciate the classmates
that I had even more like all the
experience we brought in that had
nothing to do with the kind of
traditional business finance or
something like that
awesome yeah I've heard great things
about all those classes but I haven't
taken any of them so gotta get him on my
list for next year
so my favorite class so far without a
doubt has been the sports management
class so it's taught by George Foster as
well as to practitioners so the way that
works is we have a regular Stanford
professor accompanied with one or two
industry leaders so that that'll happen
in a bunch of classes especially in
electives and our two practitioners were
Dave cavil who's the president of the
Oakland A's and Sam hinkie who's former
general manager for the Philadelphia
76ers and what I like so much about the
class was so aside from having these
people who have done so much in the
industry and are such big names was it
was really guest speaker led so we'd
have a different guest speaker or two
every week we had people including the
president of the San Francisco Giants we
had leaders from the WNBA leaders from
really all the major sports in the US
and some internationally and the class
was almost just a conversation between
the students the professor the
practitioners and our guests and it
really gave us an inside look into all
these different industries and if you're
interested in the sports industry it's
such a no-brainer class and if you're
just interested in sports in general
it's just a fascinating view into the
world that you just typically just don't
get that's great yeah and I'll add that
I think it's funny that we're all all
our favorite classes are so tied to the
things that we're interested in one of
my favorite classes that I've taken so
far is called family business and it's
by just be grabbed leo lynn beck who
flew out from texas every week to teach
this test and what was really
interesting for me was that his
perspectives were so different and you
know it's like a different vantage point
from tech and so it was really fun to
hear his take on how you run and grow
family businesses so pivoting a little
bit away from the classroom setting
another question has come in about
beyond the HBS a what types of
organizations and our resources are
available at Stanford for Hispanic
students let's speak a little of that
yeah so I mean for me there's there's a
center on campus Oh Santa Roach economy
Latino so it's it's for the general
community at large so there they have
tons of events cultural events it's a
space that you kind of just use go and
hang out you'll meet a ton of folks from
other programs so I mean I I think maybe
I met two other MBAs and everyone else
was from other programs so it's just
another space and another avenue to
explore to get to know the broader
community at Stanford the Latino
community at Stanford so that that's one
thing I would definitely say was a was a
good find and a really cool place to be
from my experience being from Mexico
City just the joint the joint
collaborations that there are between
HPSA and last I which is the Latin
American Student Association are just a
great way of kind of understanding those
two different perspectives and there are
two communities that are really
supportive with each other so those
things I think are also great resources
to you know make advantage oh yeah and
then I know HPSA last week had a mixer
bringing together different Latino
groups from different grad programs so
that was a fun way to meet people on I
think we're planning to do more of those
events this year yeah and I couldn't
make it but I know that students from
the law school were there the medicals
awesome I love that okay next question
is about Sanford and how Sanford helps
foster diversity and inclusion can you
guys speak to that sure I mean
so starting I believe in week zero
there's a kickoff event called engage
which brings together practitioners who
do diversity equity and inclusion work
outside outside in the Bay Area they're
consultants for different companies so
that's a day-long presentation where
you're with your section and you go
through different exercises just to
establish a culture of inclusivity in
your section and then hopefully that
extends to your class I'm a member of
the Diversity Committee as part of the
Student Association so I have a vantage
point our planning for next year so
we're planning to continue that program
and build upon it and some exciting ways
beyond that there are numbers student
identity groups like HBS a like Los like
be BSA which is the black business
Student Association so I think that
those groups all run fantastic events
that recur throughout the year so you
get a consistent feeling of inclusivity
and belonging throughout your class but
also between classes and day ones and a
twos
we're also working with the
administration to push different
initiatives forward to recruit even more
diverse few points and students to come
in to future classes yeah and I I
wouldn't give another push towards kind
of the admissions process I've been
blown away by the diversity of our class
both physical diversity ethnic diversity
diversity of thought diversity a
background really any anything you're
interested in mabye crown-piece anything
you're interested in there's magically
someone who has that as deep knowledge
in that specific area which always blows
my mind but I really think that that the
admissions team does a fantastic job of
bringing in people from all over the
world with with all different kinds of
experiences all different kinds of
strengths weaknesses and and and career
plans and aspirations and I think that
makes for really you know really strong
group dynamics and kind of a safe space
to kind of be different and have
different ideas different thoughts and
just just to add on that I also think
that if you find that the group
an identity group or something doesn't
exist on campus you can create it and
you'll find the people that fit that
group so I'm working with some students
here to start the first-generation
low-income group we haven't had one
before we weren't sure exactly what the
interest would be we sent out an email
we got about 50 responses back and over
one hundred over a hundred oh yeah there
it is so over a hundred now of people
who either you know identify such or
want to be advocates of such a program
so you know just just the fact that we
were able to do that just put it in
place you know it was it was a fairly
smooth transition between us and
administration and you know just this
again its diversity continues to change
and evolve I think you'll be you'll be
able to find a place on campus to create
what you want I think what I would add
is just outside the formal structures of
like clubs and societies and
associations I think there's a real
interest in from people who just to
understand other perspectives right so
like for example I think I see here more
than in other schools or perhaps just in
other experiences I've had like that
people will really you know go above and
beyond to you to understand the
different perspectives so they'll be
like okay let's organize like small
group dinners to talk about this
particular topic that perhaps we're not
really you know digging deep enough to
understand it or let's organize ask me
anything or let's do X type of event or
can you share with us what it's like to
work in this country or this other
country and I think that interest in
that how yeah like how curious and how
open the community is and how much it
translates that curiosity into something
tangible that people can take away with
them really helps with diversity and
inclusion just on you know bringing all
these things together into your MBA
experience absolutely and can you just
expand on what ask me anything czar for
audience that you know sure um so it is
like it's an informal session where you
know somebody will volunteer and you can
ask them anything for about nine minutes
and so it's just enough
you need to get to know people better
like I think I've been as really
interesting questions from my background
from places I've lived in and I've also
you know unexpectedly found out
something really random about a
classmate for example one of my
classmates it turns out he used to play
a classic music like professionally and
we had no clue he he was a musician so
you'll always find out something really
interesting and really fun about someone
but also like you can you can really you
know understand a perspective when it
comes to diversity a lot better
absolutely and one of the favorite
questions for AMAs as always what
matters most to you and why ok another
question that's come in and kind of
going off of what you were saying David
and was about any of us being first time
MBAs and our family and if so how did
you navigate some of the challenges of
the application and internship process
so maybe by show of hands who's the
first time MBA in your family okay great
so can we speak to a little bit of the
challenges and we yeah so I can start so
I think for me you know navigating these
waters for the first time there's always
kind of you deal with a lot of different
things one you may not understand how
the process works another part is
self-doubt and and really not sure where
you're gonna fit into the pile of
amazing applicants and you know what
what I did is I really first thing I
think is important is to understand that
being vulnerable throughout the entire
process is power so whether it be
reaching out to alumni and asking
questions or you know putting yourself
out there at an admissions event to talk
to admissions officer and ask the
questions that you really really need to
understand
no going in and breaking down your own
narrative and owning that narrative I
think are all part of the application
process that truly allowed me to grow
into not just being comfortable applying
or going through the challenge but also
just kind of saying owning myself and my
story regardless of whether I was going
to get into Stanford or not so I think
that was really big for me I also had a
little bit of fun with it right so my
family didn't know what an MBA was so I
had to find educating them and kind of
like walking them through the process
and I brought them into kind of the
application process and having that
support even if it's not you know when I
applied to an MBA I did this but just
saying like hey like what do you think
about this story you remember when this
happen and we would kind of reminisce
and you know really helped me think
through my narrative and story so I
think even if your family or the people
around you are not quite familiar with
it bring them into the process because
in the end of the day it's about owning
your narrative in your story that was
really well paid hard to follow I think
I would echo what David just said but I
would really emphasize don't be shy
about turning to mentors and seeking
those people out whether or not they
have an MBA I had to explain the
decision to my family and they didn't
understand like oh but you went to a
good undergrad program why do you need
this degree and I realized I wasn't
happy and the career I'd chosen and that
I needed an MBA to pivot to things that
I cared or rather I wanted an MBA in
order to affect change at a greater
scale and towards something that I cared
about so I really relied on my mentors
that I had cultivated in both the office
setting but also from years before an
undergrad and they were really helpful
in terms of navigating the process and
again like helping me flush out my story
like David said and not being shy about
being vulnerable and honest about the
experiences that had shaped me and why I
thought I would be a good candidate here
I think another thing to look into is
that there are programs out there that
help specifically black and Hispanic
potential MBA applicants like MLT
management leaders for tomorrow so you
know - David's point and to Madison's
point seek out you know informal mentors
put yourself out there and and really
look for
ways that that you can you know become
more informed on the MBA application
process to give yourself kind of the
opportunity to put your best foot
forward and I don't wanna speak for the
group that folks who are watching I'd be
happy to talk to anyone who's watching
us questions see you can always get in
touch with us and we'll have more
information about how to get in touch
with us towards the end okay so first
you know and our families to get MBAs
navigating which programs to choose
we're now at Stanford what's been most
surprising about this experience was
there anything unexpected the degree of
personal change the program ignites I
mean like we all go in here wanting to
refine and improve our like sub skills
leadership skills and you expect all
that but I don't think that you really
understand like how about you're putting
yourself up to you know expose yourself
to to really question perhaps like
fundamental things about yourself or
about your career so it may be like what
we spoke about that you may just have a
complete you know 180 change of what you
want to do in life but it may also be
things like you may understand something
about yourself through this whole like
leadership development or through other
interactions that you didn't know or you
hadn't thought about before or you
hadn't recognized what impact it has on
others and so that really feels like
this you know this motivation and this
passion to grow and to challenge
yourself but it's you know sometimes
it's tough because you're gonna have to
make difficult decisions about your
career and you know your personal life
and yourself but I think that's what's
great you know it was a surprise that it
would be such a big scale like change
perhaps but um but it's something really
satisfying so I would echo a lot of what
she just said you know like I said I
believe that volunteer lose power that's
why I was attracted to Stanford I had no
idea I was not prepared for how much
that was the case so yeah you know we
discuss AMAs there's also a talk series
where you know one of our classmates
will go up and share their NER
and even in lead labs like I think all
of us cried and Lee Labs at one point
and there's you know touchy-feely which
is a class I haven't taken yet
apparently everyone cries and you know I
just think that's really unique to
Stanford IIIi don't know many other you
know I talk I know I have a lot of
friends other than BA programs I don't
think that's always the case and one
thing I would also add to is how much
resources are available here I think you
also have an idea that an MBA program is
gonna have a lot of great resources but
if I think of something it exists and
and it's something that's valuable and I
can take advantage of so I think you
know allowing yourself to be open to
everything and to really look for the
resources that are out there already I
mean there's just so much to take
advantage of that that was one of the
biggest surprises for me yeah I've been
surprised by how much learning takes
place outside of the classroom and I
think we said that a lot in the
beginning but our classmates have really
been such a source of insight different
perspective out of our comfort zones
often times you'll find yourself at a
small group dinner and realize like oh
I've found myself at a small group
dinner like oh I'm the only American
here and just the learning and the
openness that people will bring to the
table has shocked me I think I also have
been really surprised at how busy we've
been in just how how much we're
constantly forced to make trade-offs
like we talked about the the mixer that
HPSA hosted the other night and I
couldn't make it because there were
literally three other things happening
and there was this wonderful screening
taking place that a film a documentary
called groomed and that a GSB alumna and
put together and I just couldn't miss it
but I think I've been really surprised
at the amount the optionality I guess
and just like all the things happening
and really the the reality that we can't
take it all in and I'm reminded of how
you know Disneyland wasn't designed to
allow you to like go on every ride in
one day or
even a week I mean in the GSP is that
way you have two short years here and
it's really not designed for you to take
every class and do everything but to
kind of make your own you know pick what
you want from the buffet I think you
guys completely covered everything I've
done of cool so we have a career
question how does the campus recruiting
process work at the GSB and what types
of resources to Stanford offer I can
give you this one off so there's all
different there's a few different types
of processes so one there are a set of
companies in a set of industries that
will do formal on-campus recruiting
they'll have info sessions in perhaps in
around November or December
they have formal application processes
and interview processes that they've
been doing and coordinating with
Stanford career team for for years and
years and years you know that's kind of
stuff like consulting and Investment
Banking some of the tech companies and
then aside from that we have I think one
of the best resources is just the alumni
so I've been blown away I guess one of
the things that's surprised me most is
how how helpful the alumni have been and
how responsive they've been when I just
cold reach out via email to to an alum
that's in an industry that's relevant
for me so that's been a great source
there's also a never-ending list of
internships and so we're all first-year
so we're we were more experienced with
the internship recruiting process but a
never-ending list of internships posted
that you know kind of scroll through and
have alerts set up to kind of forward me
stuff that's in a location or industry
I'm interested in and then lastly
started to take all the take so many of
these but we have a pretty large career
team and no matter the industry you're
in how large or how small there is
a career advisor dedicated to your
industry so for sports for example
there's maybe only a couple people each
year that are interested in that there's
actually a career advisor blend that
with yesterday who specializes in sports
so that's that's been a great resource
for me as well and then on the flip side
there's also someone on the career team
or a team on the career on the Stanford
career team that works on reaching out
to different companies and establishing
formal formal connections with between
them and Stanford and again there's
there's someone dedicated to sports
despite how how how nisha it might seem
[Music]
one thing I would add we have blast
email which is a sort of a list that
connects all the NBA ones and ba twos
and people just throw different
opportunities out from their old
companies etc even networking with
students in our class or in BA choose
they'll know someone who knows someone
who's looking for an intern so that's a
good resource as well as student clubs I
would say but beyond that I think Danny
covered it I mean the only thing I would
add which is something that I'm doing
this summer it's taking advantage of the
global experiences so there's G mix
which is the opportunity for you to go
and work for a company for a minimum of
four weeks in a different country that
you've never like lived or worked in and
so it just gives you the chance to you
know explore a new location perhaps a
new industry it's really it's a really
easy way to do that and so there's G mix
which is through the GSB there's also
kind of broader Stanford opportunities
like through seed which is a program
that we have to help entrepreneurs in
the developing world like build up their
management skill set and then towards
the end of the program they get access
to offer internships as well to the
Stanford community so then that's
something that business students can
also tap into if they're interested in
in working in emerging markets
yeah I guess one thing to add it's not
necessarily a formal resource but I
would say there's a lot of things that
happen here that are informal so the
cool thing about going to Stanford and
having a Stanford MBA is that the
majority of people you reach out to
whether it's a cold emo or something of
that nature they'll reach back out to
you so I'm going into an industry that
there's not a lot of like recruiting
that goes on so a lot of it had to be me
hitting the ground and I know it sounds
kind of intimidating at first but you
realize like that's kind of part of
being at Stanford of being in the
entrepreneurial environment there's also
a lot of other classmates who I think
you know for a lot of folks coming to an
MBA they feel like okay an MBA is kind
of the means to the end and you realize
like the MBA is a means in and of itself
and folks will come in thinking that
they're ready to hit this recruiting
cycle and then you taught them now
they're kind of like yeah you know I'm
just gonna start my own thing or I'm
gonna create my own project for the
summer or I'm gonna join a startup to
try something new so I think that's
another thing that is unspoken but I
think a lot of things happen in that
habit yeah and to that point on the
Entrepreneurship part something we
didn't touch on was there's a wealth of
resources for people who want to start
their own companies or work for personal
sort of small startups over the summer
or full-time so there's there's
certainly no lack of resources for
entrepreneurs as well great and we're
coming towards the end of this our time
together today and one question that I
think would be great to kind of round
this out knowing what you know now about
Stanford and the GSB and this experience
if you could start all over again rewind
back to September is there anything you
would do differently or even maybe for
wine back through the application
process and before you yeah I think
going back to your point about the
resources and the optionality I wish I
would have spent a little bit more time
thinking about the path that I at least
wanted to start on when I got
I think for the first like month or two
I came kind of thinking let's be
completely open-minded
there's too much it's it's so hard to be
completely open-minded and you start to
get FOMO because you're making too many
trade-offs I think and I spent maybe a
little bit more time in the front end
just exploring what actually existed you
know coming in with some type of plan to
then pivot from would have been really
helpful I'd second that but I think I
had it from a different slightly
different take which was I think we're a
lot of people or the majority of people
here are used to being able to you know
do everything in a very short amount of
time and being very efficient and so
sometimes you're under the illusion that
you will be able to do everything once
you're here and you're not and so I
think just taking the time I think
taking some time a just to like you know
shift gears before coming to business
school really getting your priorities
you know said and then you're able to
articulate just what you're working
towards or what do you don't know that
you want to explore it's really
important because yeah you won't be able
to do everything and just being able to
prioritize makes a huge difference yeah
those are certainly well that's
definitely what I would do differently
starting at the GSP but looking back to
the application process um I think it
would have been more useful for me to
start the essay drafting process sooner
and really key into what story I wanted
to tell because I think it's important
to tell a story in your essay and that
occurred to me a little later in the
process I wish I had brainstorm that a
bit more strategically taking it back to
the to the GSB one thing I wish I would
have done differently I I think I
realized later than I would have wanted
to how Open alums and professors are to
get coffee with you to meet up with you
etc and I'm I still have another year to
go to do this but I'm just now starting
to have informal conversations with
alums have breakfast and coffee with
with professors and in my industry and I
wish I would have taken taken advantage
of that from day one as opposed to in
quarter quarter three
that's awesome I think I would echo all
that and I'm so grateful for the time we
got to spend together today so thank you
for joining and thank you to our
audience for participating in this event
and for your great questions thank you
for joining us today have a great day
[Music]